Oh
Oh
you
one of the central ideas that's
animating martin luther king jr's
thought and work as a whole and coming
out also in these two particular pieces
of letter from a Birmingham jail and the
I have a dream speech is this conception
of what he calls racial justice and when
we hear that there's a temptation of
thinking that racial is somehow some
sort of qualifier for the term justice
that you know maybe this is just a a
subdivision of a broader conception as
it's going to turn out that's not really
the case something else that we want to
keep in mind is that this is what
actually provides the the goal the end
the tell us the overarching reason for
everything else that that he's doing in
the nonviolent movement non-violent
action is supposed to be a means to this
end it's not you know and edit in itself
something that you just do for fun or
you know to stick it to the man or
anything like that it's supposed to be
leading to a state of justice some some
sort of new transformed society so we
want to look at what King thinks about
this and how he frames it because it
might seem a little bit ill defined when
you're first focusing on it there's only
a few mentions of it but there's a lot
of discussions that actually pertain to
it so we can ask this question what does
Martin Luther King mean by racial
justice yeah one thing that might be a
possible answer that we see often in our
own society would be something like
equal you know equality of treatment so
you know equal access equal opportunity
promotions within certain institutions
like say police forces or academic
institutions the election of the first
african-american president might be seen
as part of equal treatment in that way
so a step towards racial justice another
way of thinking about it is in
terms on reparations which martin luther
king by the way was actually for but
that was again just a means to an end
it's not the end in itself so why aren't
these sufficient because they don't
really change the fabric of society they
don't move towards a better state that
human beings are capable of Martin
Luther King doesn't just want to you
know put everybody down at the same low
level nor does he want it just to be you
know exactly the same all across in some
sort of middle class think he wants to
see a full realization of human
personality of human being of what it is
that our human nature affords us and
because he thinks of human beings as
primarily interrelation alanda beings
that has to happen within the framework
of society in all the little parts of
society like you know institutions or
organizations or government so it's not
just going to be equal treatment and
it's not just going to be things like
reparations I'm not going to cross that
out because that could be part of it
well what goes beyond that one of the
most robust clues about this is Kings
reference to the American dream and you
see this a bit more in the I have a
dream speech so I'm going to skip the
sections where he talks about this in
the letter from a Birmingham jail and
just you know focus on this so early on
in the eye of a dream speech he's
talking about the condition of African
Americans a hundred years more than a
hundred years after emancipation and he
said this you know there's this
declaration of emancipation raised a lot
of hopes those hopes have not been
realized what are were those hopes
raised so he says in a sense we've come
to our nation's capital to cash a check
now what does that mean the cash a check
that makes you probably think of
reparations it's not a monetary check
it's a check in terms of what it is that
America has an ideal and
nation promises to its citizens and this
is enshrined in you know the what we
call the organic law which includes the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution of the United States so he
says when the architects of our republic
wrote The Magnificent words of the
Constitution the Declaration of
Independence they were signing a
promissory note to which every American
was to fall heir this note was the
promise that all men yes black men as
well as white men would be guaranteed
the unalienable rights of life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness and then
you'll go on and say look it's pretty
clear that America has defaulted on this
promise so far that they've actually
issued a check that had insufficient
funds and you know you go to the bank
and you try to deposit in your quite
embarrassed when that happens when
african-americans try to cash in that
check oftentimes it led to much more
than embarrassment it led to things like
like you know terrorism and lynchings to
the whole segregation regime so he's
saying that the promise of America was
actually to provide all of its citizens
irrespective of color of race and
ethnicity with the same conditions the
same possibility to pursue the same
ideals the pursuit of happiness the same
protections of life and liberty and even
you know proper you ought to be rolled
in there if we want to get John Locke
yet about it so Martin Luther King is
going to frame this this long-standing
promise in terms of realizing what the
American dream was supposed to provide
to all of its citizens irrespective of
the sort of things that set them apart
for instance race ethnicity the sort of
things that allow people to be
discriminated against and just as a side
note Alexis de Tocqueville at this
French theorist who spent a lot of time
traveling around America observing
America and actually wrote a book called
democracy in America one of the things
that he noticed in 1800s and he was a
big supporter of America
and the whole you know notion of the
kind of new society that was being built
there one of the things that he called
attention to was precisely the fact that
white Americans had done a terrible job
in realizing any of this sort of
goodness any of this sort of justice any
sort of opportunities for two groups
were for the African Americans and for
Native Americans King here is primarily
talking about african-americans but this
would apply to any sort of discriminated
against class that this realization of
the American Dream is supposed to afford
you might say not only equal protection
Adi not only equal opportunity but
something more substantive so that's
going to provide him with a very
powerful metaphor that he's going to use
here let's look at the next issue he
talks about forces within the black
community that want to have segregation
in one way in which we're not segregated
separation sorry one way in which one
could think about racial justice would
be that the best way to attain it would
be to give african-americans or any
other minority their own place over here
let them govern themselves and then have
White's over here and there are some
some you know within the
african-american community at that time
who are saying look that's the best that
you're going to get you're not going to
get any justice in an integrated society
because somebody's always going to be on
top and somebody's always going to be on
bottom King says no that that that is
not what we're aiming for that's not
going to be a satisfactory resolution
it's going to have to be an integrated
society where blacks and whites and
everybody else can live next to each
other can participate in the same
institutions can engage within the same
culture can you know have dialogue can
have you know businesses together we
could just go down the line for this
sort of thing that's what racial justice
is going to require for for Martin
Luther
he talks about this is a very nice way
to frame this as being a substantive and
positive peace as opposed to a kind of
fake piece or a negative piece you know
if you just give everybody the same
thing and you don't really treat them as
if they matter or they only matter in so
far as they complain so then you give
them things to get them off your back
you're not really doing justice to the
person in the full sense he would say
what you're doing is just but it's not
the same thing as full justice so a
substantive and positive peace what
would that entail he says that it
involves respecting the dignity and
worth of personality so here we see a
connection to you know his whole
discussion of just and unjust laws just
laws are those which uphold and uplift
human personality that is they develop
they create the conditions for the
development the flourishing of human
beings as the kind of beings that we are
not just as productive beings not just
as intellectual beings but also as
social beings as beings in relationship
with each other as beings that matter to
each other unjust laws were laws that
damaged or degraded or suppressed
personality that treats some people as
if they don't matter as if they're just
things rather than persons so the state
that he's looking for is is a case in
which you know we could say it's all
just laws there are no unjust laws not
even in application and everybody is
dignity everybody is worth is being
respected that doesn't mean that
everybody is going to be a nice person
some people are still going to be
screw-ups in the kind of society that
he's talking about but at least they
won't be screw-ups because they've been
you know beaten and repressed so long
that they're filled with hatred and
resentment if you know at that point in
this sort of society they're still
screw-ups it's on them you could say but
we'll get to that in a moment when we
talk about you have quality on you know
another way of thinking about this he's
got these passages where he's responding
this is a letter
from a Birmingham jail to being called
an extremist and he says yeah you want
to call me an extremist that's fine at
least I'm not a moderate sitting on the
fence doing nothing pretending like
everything is going to get better over
time I'm happy to be an extremist for
love of truth and goodness and in the
transition to racial justice that would
be the sort of thing that would be going
on as a matter of fact what we're
calling extremism in this framework
wouldn't really be extreme it would be
the norm people would treat each other
in more loving ways people would respect
truth people would try to enact goodness
towards each other rather than that you
know the opposites finally he's got a
another great phrase he talks about a
beautiful symphony of brotherhood and if
you linger over this metaphor for a
moment what does a symphony like if you
have ever listened to classical music
it's really remarkable when you pay
attention to what's going on within a
symphony you have all these different
instruments and they're playing
different things but they somehow come
together even symphonies that use
dissonance you know really modern stuff
like Debussy or prokofiev or
Shostakovich people like that everything
has been arranged in such a way that the
musicians are able to harmonize and
synchronize with each other so that
their individual actions are not
impeding the other person's individual
actions or harming them but they're
actually building something that's
greater than themselves Martin Luther
King is not thinking of this in musical
terms he's thinking of this in moral
terms in terms of what he's calling here
Brotherhood or that you know treating
other people as again human persons as
treating treating them as if they matter
as if what they're trying to do the
things that they develop into can fit in
with other people without without
this is an ideal this is what he is
trying to strive for he's not saying
that this will be completely realized in
his lifetime it certainly wasn't a
hundred years from then probably won't
be even perhaps a thousand years but
these are ideals that allow him to have
something to shoot for now one question
that's really important that remains is
is this a society in which everybody
gets a gold star in which you know if to
respect personality means we have to you
know care about everybody else's
self-esteem all the time and pretend
like everybody's a winner no actually
that would be to go against what he's
talking about in terms of justice you
know go certainly go against truth if
you're not good at mathematics because
you didn't put in the work to study and
didn't do the homework you shouldn't get
the same grade as the person who
actually improved themselves so you know
ways got that line in there about I have
a dream a lot of people i think don't
actually consider they don't listen to
the first part of the line and they
don't think about the second part when
he says i have a dream that my four
little children will one day live in a
nation where they will not be judged by
the color of their skin there's the
first part but by the content of their
character to judge somebody on the
content of their character means to
actually say you're a good person or
you're a bad person and to be able to
provide reasons why to be able to say
well you know you're you steal from
everybody all the time and we've SAT you
down and showed you that it's hurting
other people and you say I don't care I
want the stuff that would be a bad
character and one could legitimately say
you're not as good of a person as this
person over here or keeps their hands
off of other people's stuff it actually
helps them out on the weekends you know
improving their their their places a lot
of people like I said just just focus on
the you know not being judged on the
color of skin
the not judgment the equalising
everything and they don't focus on the
fact that martin luther king is a very
strong advocate for judging on the
content of character one of the main
problems with segregation as he's
pointing it out is the detrimental
damaging effects that it has on the
human character on human personality so
in a certain way to you know be judged
by the content of one's character is to
be treated as a full human being it's to
be treated as somebody who has the
possibility for realizing what humanity
is now you notice that I've got another
topic over here that's connected with
this issue of racial justice King will
talk about what you know this this
notion of mutuality and he talks about a
mutuality of justice and injustice what
is mutuality mean it means that were not
all alone that we can't be completely
isolated from each other he says that
all communities and States so that is
all local communities every you know
sort of organization and every nation is
interrelated with others and you could
say well maybe that's a modern
phenomenon may be king is only talking
about the modern world in which he's
he's living but that is certainly the
case for the world that we live in today
even states that attempt to you know
wall themselves off like for example
North Korea they have refugees flowing
over into China that the Chinese have to
figure out what to do with you know you
can get information in and out there is
an inter connection there is a smaller
world that we all live in he also says
that injustice anywhere is a threat to
justice everywhere this is a stronger
statement to say that all the nations
all the communities are connected with
each other is not yet to say that what's
going on over there actually affects us
over here and this is not talking about
direct effect at this point it's talking
about indirect effect about you know
posing a threat so injustice
anywhere is a threat to justice
everywhere else the degree of justice
that has been realized communities
nations that haven't quite got it
together haven't moved towards through
social progress towards a more equitable
situation are not just you know dragging
the rest behind they could become the
norm like King has said you know in
other places there is no historical
inevitability to civil rights being
granted it requires good people to
actually put themselves at risk to you
know put their action out there in the
world for things like that to happen he
says oppressors do not give up their
power willingly it's only when people
stand up for for themselves or stand up
for others who are experiencing
injustice somewhere else which is the
case that's why he's writing a letter
from a Birmingham jail he saying to
those who are criticizing is actually
worth worth reading directly he says I
am in Birmingham which is not where he
lives it's a different community because
injustice is here he says I can add sit
by idly in Atlanta and not be concerned
about what happens in Birmingham
injustice anywhere is a threat to
justice everywhere we are caught in an
inescapable network of mutuality tied in
a single garment of destiny whatever
affects one directly affects all
indirectly and so he draws this
conclusion that we cannot afford to live
with this narrow provincial outside
agitator idea anyone who lives inside
the United States can never be
considered an outsider anywhere in its
bounds so if injustice is taking place
in Chicago that affects you and me even
if we're not living in Chicago if
injustice is taking effect in a very
different way in Texas then that affects
all of us of course it affects those who
are directly impacted by it more but
indirectly it affects all of us we all
have a stake in a few things so the
freedoms of people are connected
together in fact in the eye of a dream
speech he's lauding he's
raising the people who join with the
civil rights struggle precisely for
realizing that their freedom which they
think it you know they couldn't just
think is just their own freedom like the
white moderates do is in fact connected
with the freedom of those who are
suffering one way to realize this is to
try to go down and change things and he
talks about you know some of the whites
who decided to join the civil rights
struggle finding out what it was like in
the segregated south because they got
thrown into jails as well and beaten and
called all sorts of names he also talks
more globally about there's this term
that he's a zeitgeist that I want to
explain because you might not know it
and talks about the zeitgeist for
oppressed peoples worldwide having
changed so he talked about Africa
judgment Asia he talks about the
Caribbean and he says you know there are
struggles going on for liberation and
for equal rights for justice for
something greater than the colonial
regimes happening in all these places
that's part of why we're doing that the
struggle right now when we talk about
zeit guess what that literally means is
the spirit or the mentality of the times
I tis time dice is mind or spirit and in
German and so the zeitgeist is you might
say the spirit of the age and what we're
looking at in the 1950s the 1960s is
this this realization that you know
racial justice is something that could
be realized it's not just something for
you know concerning the American South
racial justice was a concern in all the
colonial areas and remember shortly
before this most of the world was a
European colony of one sort or another
so the zheng kai's changing just
reinforces this notion of mutuality and
king will be concerned with what is
going on in other places as well as in
america so now we know what does he mean
by racial justice this whole substantive
conception of a trance
information not only of society but of
human nature itself allowing it to fully
develop